ça c'est une voiture hélicoptère avion
c'est une voiture à lavage c'est un peu
bizarre de voir comme ça mais c'est vrai
et en fait vous allez pouvoir aller sur
la route vous allez pouvoir rouler et
ensuite vous envoler vous allez pouvoir
vous envoler soit la verticale comme un
hélicoptère ou alors carrément rouler
sur une piste de décollage et lorsque
vous avez suffisamment de vitesse vous
en voulez comme un avion après on
atterrit et vous roulez comme une
voiture vous avez deux vrais places à
l'avant devrait place également à
l'arrière c'est un hybride en fait hier
vous allez avoir tout le moteur
électrique et si vous voulez aller un
peu plus loin et bien vous avez
également du thermique alors la boîte
qui fait ça s'appelle Aska Aska je
tourne encore les autorisations du
gouvernement américain pour pouvoir le
faire voler donc il va pouvoir bientôt
prendre le ciel et prendre la route en
tout cas si vous êtes intéressé et bien
vous pouvez venir l'acheter pour une
livraison à partir de 2026 je trouve ça
dingue de voir ce qu'on peut faire des
voitures volantes on a toujours rêvé
alors même si là c'est quand même très
gros bébé les potentiellement ça
pourrait arriver je suis très heureux de
pas vous présenter d'ailleurs dites-moi
est-ce que vous vous verriez vous dans
une voiture volante oui ou alors non pas
du tout parce que le moi dans les
commentaires